this doesn't make sense it does not make
sense
it's all wrong
what is
[Music]
everything are you okay we have to
question everything we know about
Alzheimer's if we're gonna cure it she's
back Ellen Pompeo makes her big Gray's
Anatomy return in the season 19 finale
that's the house that gray built yes so
she's always there looming she just has
to step away for a little bit the
doctors of gray Sloan make a trip to
Boston where Meredith now lives for a
fundraiser the ride not as smooth as
expected
commercial
well they safely land and find
themselves in Meredith's lab where she
shares her new medical Theory
when's the last time you slept well
Jackson had to go to London to manage a
crisis so I called all of you here
because you all know me better than
anyone else does and I need to run this
past you before I tell anyone else
a possible new theory on Alzheimer's but
mayor doesn't have full support from her
old colleagues I see inconsistencies but
mirror why you are hypothesizing insults
Decades of Genius work
insults Derek's work if you make this
public there's a possibility you could
lose your funding and your reputation
maintain the respect that you have built
for yourself while her career might be
on the line Meredith's love life is
looking up we got some resolution about
that whole thing with Dr Nick Marsh I
love you
all welcome to the first day I met you
yeah a love confession right before
Meredith moved East I did pretend not to
hear you I was tired and scared and
overwhelmed and I know that sounds
stupid but I thought that what I should
do in that moment was to focus on the
children so that's what I did and as you
can tell I'm still tired and scared and
overwhelmed and I probably just blew up
my career but
I miss you and the scary plane ride had
Nick thinking about her too I never
should have let you walk away and to say
that
and pain
oh crazy
[Music]
foreign
back on the show was a treat for fans
who said goodbye for now to the Beloved
TV doc back in February for the record
it's not really my final it's a little
bit about the trick they're playing on
people it is my final episode for a
while Ellen remains part of the show as
the narrator and an executive producer
but what about seeing more of Mayor on
screen well if you ask Gray's Anatomy
Creator Shonda Rhimes she says the door
is always open Ellen's spectacular and I
think she deserves a little bit of
creative time that's different from what
she's been doing she's been doing this
job I mean nobody expected the show to
go this many seasons we're entering the
20th season so she deserves the break
and get a chance to sort of do something
else and if she wants to come back she
comes back
[Music]